well hello reject nation I'm Greg Alba
the best hair in the world and I'm Tara
Erickson with you in better hair in the
world better hair in the world hey Tara
have you ever told a lie hey Gregory
Alba I do it all the time
me too but let's see how good Jimmy
Fallon and Margot Robbie are okay box of
lies have you seen the same Mr got it I
think it's Margot hi I'm telling you her
mom's pretty mad at you right was me
trying to lie she's like Australian
Margot Robbie has an American mother
[Laughter]
okay here we go here we go do it you've
seen this segment I haven't my favorite
Jimmy Fallon's objects neither of us
have seen before taking turns we're
going to select a box and open it on our
side of the table out of view of the
other person you remove the object from
the box show it to the audience and then
you have to they have to guess if you're
lying or telling the truth we play three
rounds
[Music]
she American ladies British I think
she's oh I can see the box is bit heavy
[Music]
really saucy something saucy ah it's
kinda sexy like I I mean you kind of in
it okay because it's your head and it's
like the body on a carrot like just the
red dress lady Jessica Rabbit
yeah I'm Roger Rabbit yes your head my
head I've never been in doubt for him
really so it's my head baby someone made
my head and put it on it Jessica Rabbit
mom it's a bubble head so the second
Paul head doll I did have it Bowen are
you yeah but the bobble heads a giant
head it'd have to be a giant Jessica
Rabbit I don't know but he's just
physically see right there he didn't set
out because busted yourself I think
[Applause]
they're supposed to lie every time right
no use it you got it you got to tell you
got to determine whether they're lying
or telling the truth really real about
sex because they're so absurd what's in
there it's ice cream in a in a in a
looks like a Houston Astros have a
baseball help side down baseball hat but
interesting enough they had a Trump hair
it looks like Trump hair is sprinkled on
top and ice cream ice cream in any
plastic upside down baseball cap
she was going to church you should've
just gone with the church you're holding
several wins the next round wins
[Applause]
[Music]
listen Margot there we go
Oh Thank You Ruth playing music I can't
hear anything all right
this is all part of the thing reactions
sure it's kind of like you could use
this is what could be on YouTube you
could use it as a paperweight okay but
you probably wouldn't but you could if
you wanted to it's kind of like a like a
dish like a salad e-glass crystal a bowl
it's filled with band-aids that's kind
of literally making [ __ ] up I wouldn't
be able to tell ya like a little toy you
kind of you kind of lost your accent a
little bit describing it so that like
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
lose-lose-lose what was anybody else
being like wow her nipple is gonna slip
out when she picked up that heavy box I
was that jumper I was like no bra there
have you seen the wolf of Wall Street
oh sure how man everyone became a fan of
Margot Robbie after that movie 43 at
Tati only her acting only for her
telling her talent I don't remember most
scenes in that movie but I do remember
do you remember Margot acting she just
really was exposed her is her soul
there's really the wolf of wallstreet
old say the wolf came out on me you know
what movie is she promoting right now
come on this tonight's show you're hot
yeah all right look I got a little game
we could play oh my gosh let's play it I
love games
I'll tell a story and you got a
determine whether or not online yes I
love it go tell me the story oh and I'll
determine five to tell story - okay you
go first
in seventh grade yeah I'm gonna tell her
like how people tell it in box a lot in
seventh grade mm-hmm I sat next to a
girl named
alejandra uh-huh and you're lying and
Alejandra I'm already and I we had desks
our next to each other
uh-huh and and then she went to the
bathroom Wow
and then after she went to the bathroom
I saw she had this this case of mints
oh did she yes and I took I took a
couple then they dropped on my my pants
and then as she was coming back from the
bathroom and I didn't want her to know I
stole some mints right so I just like
took them and I swallowed in a closer
case mm-hmm but then a friend of hers
snitched on me and they started laughing
at me
mm-hmm because they they ended up
actually me my doll oh yeah and then the
whole class heard and then other grades
heard and everyone's like grid you take
my doll you you that's my story how far
apart were the desks we oh they're right
next to each other so I when you have
the two students you need to make room
and then you have like one desk next to
each other right yeah Alejandra what was
her last name uh Gonzalez Fisher right
mm-hmm I already knew and he was like I
had a friend Alejandra am i lying or
telling the truth that sounds really
realistic I don't think he but the
beginning I was like he's that's the
whole point you're supposed to make it
sound like you're lying
you could find me on la casting if you'd
like so Tara go ahead tell a story okay
there was this one time that I was in
Hawaii and I was in this the pool in the
whatever like ocean tide pool saltwater
whatever and it was like a there was a
dolphin there okay and there were also
other people there because it was like
an interaction thing like you could get
you could get in the pool water in
Hawaii right swim around okay
but I remember kind of swim around and
they they were like they were feeding
the Dolphins and like they would do
stuff and they were like doing tricks
with the Dolphins they'd be like Oh send
him to job and like roll roll around
yeah tricks and that's cool but then one
of them came up to me and totally like
nibbled on my on my belly button and I
was like what and I remember jumping up
and out like almost like going to get
out of the pool and then the trainer
lady there was like no no it's okay and
like she smacked the water and then that
means for the dolphin to go to her and
then he swam to her but I was just set
up on the deck the whole the whole rest
at the time with my feet just in the
water cuz I was like this dude he's
trying to eat me in stuff you know it
was a whole it was it was a it was
interesting when did you go to Hawaii
back in 2005 this was 12 years ago when
this happen oh yeah who'd you go with I
was by myself you went to Hawaii by
yourself yeah you just took a trip to
Hawaii by yourself oh yeah it was like a
it was a prolonged trip because I was
there for actually seven months oh
you're lying
Am I
I'm telling the truth that's the Big
Island of Hawaii
on my facebook what you look at the wife
for that long I used to be a dolphin
trainer
don't know why why call the village and
you want to know who bit my belly button
his name was alone oh and he was a 500
pound dolphin and he was a dude and I
was like man you need to get your stuff
together
my favorite dolphin was my Cana he never
he never was weird he was always very
really
I'll bring pictures next time I come to
visit him of me and McConaughey's
adorable I think what this this game has
taught us is that Tara and I are not
quick enough to improvise I could sound
believable enough but kind of ridiculous
gotcha you got me I want that crazy
experience I hear them back there going
wow she did a lot better than him we'll
see
uh-huh who do you think had the better
hat that you have a way more interesting
it's the better story well I mean taking
my doll as a teen and then having also
all your peers see you take my doll is
oh it was embarrassing but as you can't
I liked anything that garnered attention
yeah you're just carrying around a
bottle that clearly says I don't okay my
half you know how like Lucy has the
vitami to veg Minh because every period
of class math English art would have
different girls in there a different
group he just popped the bottle out and
be like I wonder who's looking and he
wouldn't take him until everyone's like
Oh what do you got there oh just some my
tall I would act like I couldn't see
like oh yeah you just happened to catch
me oh you just happen to catch me taking
some midol thanks for our game Jimmy
Fallon we do it how can we actually make
commentary on that subscriber the real
rejects click that notification bell
more importantly please follow Kara
Erickson yeah
Tara Erickson YouTube channel I'll just
tell you guys her channel is so funny
and so worth it and if you subscribe you
are not only making her happy you're
making me happy I was doing dancing
their idiot army he's part of it cuz as
you can see with the evening the mic
hashtag the city it looked me up on
YouTube you know where to find me you
know how plugs go by